- [Announcer] Take your
fitness to the next level,
with the tuenfit 4s.
The pulse tracking wrist band
that gets you in shape,
on and off the field.
tunefit 4s measures
distance traveled, steps,
and floors climbed, all at
the flick of your wrist.
So you can chart your progress all day
with a variety of useful steps.
tunefit 4s automatically
monitors your sleep
to show you how well you've
slept and for how long.
And if you're sleeping with anybody.
How's that going?
Use social mode to connect
with out tunefit community.
Look how in shape and attractive they are.
And now you can share your workout results
with the rest of the world.
Feeling stressed?
Breath tracker analyzes and corrects
your breathing patterns,
pulse, and sexual frustrations.
- [Device] Breathe now, breathe now.
- [Announcer] You'll also stay motivated
with tuner penalty,
which keeps you in check
if you fail to meet your goals.
- Um, can I get a?
- [Announcer] If you miss
runs, consume bad calories,
or continue being single,
you'll lose points.
Because unhealthy eating
and lifestyle decisions
not only kill you, they
keep you alone forever.
(device beeps)
We believe the path to a better life,
is right in front of you.
And it's really not
that hard at all, Kate.
Stop running from your problems,
And start running toward
your solutions, Kate.
Make every breath count,
because breath is limited
and you only have so many before you die.
And you don't want to die alone, right?
Are you still single?
What happened to all of your goals?
How's your dating going, Kate?
- [Device] Fail, fail.
(Kate screams)
(exciting music)
- [Announcer] tunefit 4s,
we're talking to you, Kate.
(exciting music)
- Help!